step aside Kim because Kylie Jenner may
have just broken the damn Internet
the 22 year old makeup mogul posed for
the cover of Playboy's fall 2019
pleasure issue I'm obsessed with it and
inside the mag her man Travis Scott asks
all the burning questions and nothing is
off-limits now we're breaking down the 7
most shocking things we learned from her
Playboy sit down starting with this
Kylie dishes on the secret sauce to her
in Travis's relationship revealing that
they have the same goals and passions in
life quote besides the fact that we have
good chemistry we have a lot of fun
together you're my best friend and get
ready for some pillow talk because Kylie
says that becoming a mom to one-year-old
stormy hasn't affected her sex life one
tiny bit and she tells Travis that he is
partially to thank for that
quote you remind me that motherhood and
sexuality can coexist and just because
you embrace your sexuality doesn't mean
you have loose morals or you're not a
good mother I just love my body you can
be sexy and still be a badass mom cute
but also let's give it up to being 22
anyway since the issue was all about
pleasure
Travis asked Kylie what the word
pleasure means to her and her answer it
might surprise you quote I get pleasure
in doing things that people say I can't
do which brings us to number 4 on our
list when Travis mentions that he
overheard Kylie talking about expanding
her brand to include wine and linens she
explained quote you probably overheard
us trademarking everything in different
categories so that if I ever decide to
come out with wine or bed linens it'll
be set up
I can't wait to keep expanding and
creating new things makeup skincare wine
and bedding okay
and while kylie is making that
Kardashian money her days off with
Travis are less glam than you might
think
do something fun
she says it's all about playing with
their daughter but when stormy goes to
sleep they're ready to Netflix and chill
quote we usually fight over what TV show
we're going to watch we have a lot of
fun together we're always laughing or
getting into deep talks oh and on the
topic of deep talks the girl can write
like Shakespeare well not Shakespeare
but you know the girl can rape okay well
she likes to write quote I actually just
love writing and putting together words
writing just helps me feel better and
express myself and last but not least
kylie reveals her secret to self care
and good news guys it's free 99 I only
keep positive people and positive energy
around me I stay close to my family and
love family time and a good skincare
routine gotta get that Kylie skincare
promotion in there love it love it so
much
of course et will be here to keep you up
with the Kardashian Jenner's so make
sure to subscribe to all things et until
next time I'm Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]